austria president
rodgers was correct and windy in front of dates
intenze the parliament with
alternative rock on when do i get
you ask the result of these days
long to beijing far away in spain has
come the
recklinghauser budget tricks are in
budgetary these plans the european
night  was heard
you come here the budgets you come the
judges
rotenburg the rotenburg in europe and
you show it again efficiently whether the
moment formation sink in the world
migrates media offers innovative
green realize it depend europe the
in the most sensitive before the now
really marburg with to hamburg  the
ford brand next year and red us
right
infrastructure strengthening program was the
freighter is the ineffectiveness wants to
have proven something erasmus
horizon is windy end connect europe
facility okay he says i would have
shaved in the budget shortage is among
the surveys mother nature you come in
the same  e direction in roding
which again günther was
allowed to have absolutely more about europe offers and drive on sight
and national level in the top
innova you competent climatic
restrictive insured michael b i say
out of caution budget committee people
were with the grandma secretary of state
who got the
result was  the low before research
by the budget speech committee
top what we think is not an old
market that is in
fact so special are so lisbon opera
fecter said magath the market waited
for the respective gap fits yes whether
start in fanatic then compromises
total.com premiere  comes fritz pinter
below-average rate should be strengthened by
the fraud at this meeting
the linking regard to the
objective warm to dubai waiting for help
again on tuesday grateful but
dry
thanks the president pointed out
[music]
financial thanks mr president dear
commissioner dear dear finnish
council presidency dear  ki  no
thiele none dear colleagues at
the beginning i would like to say a thank you
a thank you forgive me at the
beginning to my colleagues
negotiation topics special someone
upper field at one who should
conduct the direct negotiations with me
but also my shadow report of
the city and  to the coordinators who
intensively coach us just sent me an
address you dear colleague are looking
at me right now
we really tried
to work together to communicate with one another here
we have agreed on common positions
and i would like to thank
kino.to for not
after we
initially fought fiercely with each other
but then tried to negotiate fairly with us
and we had
common priorities and
now also provide these common priorities
financially that parliament
would have liked to have had even more, it is clear
that the council would have some
it is also clear that we would have liked to have had less, but i believe
that we have reached a good compromise.
spending 850 million more on climate protection in the area of research and innov
tion will
lso be used for jobs and for compe
itiveness for young people and for digit
zation that means that is a lot
that we can do toget
er  we were able to increase the households who
deal with climate protection by
a total of 504 million
more than 21 percent of the expenditure is
climate-related and will very
clearly exceed the 20 percent target but still have a
lot to do and on the 25 percent or
even  to get even higher
horizon 2020 experiences an increase
of 8.8 percent i have to honestly
say that you were a bit stunned to read the
unilateral declaration of the countries
that voted against, in particular
denmark, the netherlands, austria and
sweden, which says
that it is not enough in particular
people give and secondly that  it
far exceeds what is supposed to be necessary
i have to state soberly that
horizon 2020 has so many programs that are
completely oversubscribed where we can
only fund 78 percent of the programs at all
that i simply cannot understand such an
explanation
and that all
I am grateful to the member
states who share this compromise with us that there are no brands away it is
simply wrong we have 1.5 billion
marshall one
for 2020 and from the past two
years instruments up to the amount of
4.2 billion
i believe that we  really also in
this respect the wheel went too
far, but it was
also important to us the topic of climate protection
in the field of energy with 96 million c
traffic with 37 million
the european satellite systems which are also
essential in questions of
climate research erasmus youth exchange
with 50 million more  thus a total of
2.9 billion and an increase of 3.6
percent
d  ie youth employment initiative with
28.3 but if it is needed with
another 50 million from June in
case it should be necessary
that we could increase live
does not weigh as much as we would have liked
but at least
that we also have questions
we have not left out security around the topic of epo a little bit more europol a little bit that means we gave the money where
it was necessary we gave it to the
media area in kohle regions
in transition to there also essential
questions of  climate protection
i believe that we have put together an all-round solid
package i would like to thank my colleagues
very
much for supporting me so
much and to the
presidency of the council and the commission
together that we were able to successfully end the
negotiations or
decide on the top  position lost
sports
politics that must politics
moments like harry & programs in the
research and development
transport and uncertainties
president
the top league stuff dear
president ladies and gentlemen
members of parliament ladies and gentlemen dear mr thele
none on the one hand we had a
very good starting position with a very good chance of
reaching an agreement because the priorities of
parliament and council were the
On the one hand, investments in research
innovations future of Europe, on the other hand, 2
measures against climate change and,
on the other hand
, combating unemployment, creation of
jobs, especially for
the young generation  parliament 2.7
billion euros more at the council 1.5
billion euros less 4.2 billion
difference that was an exhibition situation
that was far greater than the difference in the
budget deliberations of the years before
the parliament wanted in the last
budget yes  hr of the budget framework,
if possible invest all available funds up
to the upper limit
the council wanted what I
felt to be right to a certain extent,
build up leeway for the
unforeseen in 2020 or for the
foreseeable keyword refugees who are
currently living in Turkey and for whom we
people would finance
the foreseeable but not yet
taken into account in the commission's budget proposal has benefited from the willingness to assume
responsibility and the
different awareness of all those involved
I thank the chairman for his
sovereign moderation I thank the
two rapporteurs for their
expert commitment and their
coordination with important members
of the budget committee that  a
multiple end with deputies from many
factions was achievable and i thank
the representative of the us economy they
have delivered
the power although has represented the line of the
wheel but has always reached a
result
of a compromise solution  was
interested and then worked very
constructively every second the
press wrote about dramatic
discussions in the last hour
it wasn't that dramatic i think it
has already shown that the
leading heads didn't want it to
fail but wanted an
agreement  the numbers
speak for themselves,
on the one hand, we had not touched the upper limits in
any way, but complied with them,
on the other hand, we have leeway
for a total of 1.5 billion commitments
with other
flexibility instruments of 4.2 billion euros and
are therefore armed for that  what
can be added
to the european union in the next year for the issue of climate change, we clearly exceeded the target of 20 percent in the
2020 budget with a percentage
of 21.1 percent
and thus accounted for a
significant proportion of the shortfalls in
the to  low investments in 2014
balanced again in 2015
we reached a
peak in investments from the
european budget for research and
innovation in 2020 13.5 billion euros
compared to 20 19 growth of 8.8
percent
and i would like to recommend
this highest research from hot
2020 to all those involved as a starting point for  tire
europe not to go below
because economic strength
competitiveness investments in
technologies for sustainability and
climate protection is visible here
that is why the step the trainer
thanks to parliament measures with a further
three million euros was a decisive
step of this transitional budget in
the deliberations for the budget framework
power 2020  connecting europe facility
energy significantly increased pleasure 35
percent moderately increased traffic that
means we are already investing in the
future and thus creating
added value dementia can best
be realized at European level
we have at erasmus plus immerh  an increase of four
percent this is also a small
step in the direction of doubling or
tripling if you take parliament
and mrs von der leyen as a benchmark
in the budget years of the next
decade we have also planned some
moderate cuts which in my
opinion are justifiable in implementation
keyword mr introduction  help for
turkey we have some moderate but
important reinforcements at europol
eurojust and the depot of the
public prosecutor's office so that these
instruments and bodies for internal
security and for the rule of law in
europe and for the fight against
corruption are more capable of acting they are all
in all and i can
tell you about that  a colleague from the
commission the colleagues who are responsible for the
portfolio in the
commission and from holders
implement
the commission is satisfied with this budget
is a good basis for
the implementation of the budget by the new
commission and that is why my thanks go to
al  the council involved, dear
colleague, till no discount or presidency
and i find you simply offer the enthusiasm to bring the
élan into the
deliberations on the multi-annual
budgetary framework, the ministers in the
general council would have said as long
as we said
with work intensity over two
weeks how late  in the evening at trends a
clock with this work intensity and
not just with two hours per month
and always the same line to take would
also come into the new movement and
as a citizen I hope
to read his
breakthrough for a modern framework of the
household very early next year  next decade by the council
and parliament and this does not
only happen one advent in a year,
then one would have represented budget from the good experiences of
their consultations if the
twenty learned the lesson
to a legally responsible budget framework for
the next decade and thus for more
value that one only european  can
reduce best thanks
everyone involved
[applause]